Speaker 1: OK, let's get into audience questions
for the week, some some good ones, I must
say, I'm impressed with the audience.
First question, David, what happens to drug
trafficking and the illegal drug trade if
all drugs are decriminalized or legalized?
So these are really two questions.
What happens to drug trafficking with decriminalization
is very different than what happens to drug
trafficking with legalization.
So if we just see decriminalization of drugs
in terms of possession, you're not going to
see a drastic change to trafficking.
In that case, the cartels won't really need
to change anything in order to continue being
profitable.
Operationally, I don't think that they would
see any anything major change.
But you would start to maybe see some changes
when it comes to American institutions.
Maybe at the prison level you would see some
differences, although I don't think they would
be as big as some people think.
I'm going to get back to that.
You would probably see more people suffering
from addiction willing to go and seek treatment
because of this word decriminalization.
It's no longer a criminal thing.
But I think for the most part, from a dealer
standpoint, from a cartel standpoint, from
a gang standpoint, and we know about the overlap
between drugs, drugs and gangs you would see
operating.
You would see them operating basically the
same way they do, although maybe they would
shift a little bit to areas where you could
leverage something that is still completely
criminal rather than decriminalized, but still
not really OK.
And remember that when we talk about decriminalization
and legalization, we're talking about possession
for use and the idea of when even in cases
of legalization, you still need to be licensed.
I mean, look at cigarets as an example, cigarets
which are legal.
You still see a black market for cigarets
and you still see people trying to pay less
for them by going obtaining them in ways other
than the way that the government has established
through regulation should be done.
Now, if you actually saw legalization, I think
that that would take a big bite out of the
black market.
I think you would see if there was really
full legalization where state government or
federal government or both says, as has been
done with cannabis and a lot of places already,
this is now legal.
As long as you're licensed to produce and
sell it.
There are some limits in terms of how much
any individual can have or grow.
And you need to be twenty one and you need
to be paying taxes in this way, in that type
of thing, you would still have a black market,
which would likely be cheaper and you still
see that.
But it might actually impact the level of
violence to some degree.
You I think that you would actually see a
decrease in the amount of violence, but it
would be less violence related to the production
and distribution of that substance.
You would still have gangs and cartels.
My expectation would be if you legalize more
and more drugs, you'd see gangs and cartels
go in the direction of human trafficking,
organ trafficking, extortion, kidnaping, protection.
And the sort of example or model for that
is look at the United States during alcohol
prohibition in the early 20th century.
It created a different criminal world.
And then when it was really legalized, it's
not like criminality went away.
It was a switch.
We've seen mafias switch from and to, you
know, from alcohol to gambling or prostitution
or whatever the case may be.
So then let's talk about the prison thing.
With decriminalization of personal use amounts
alone, I actually am not sure that American
prison populations would dramatically decrease.
And what I mean by that is the following.
Yes, some people do end up in prison simply
for possession of personal use.
Drugs for the most part, like overwhelmingly
people that are in prison for drugs are in
prison because they either were involved in
the trade and had amounts that are far bigger
than what would be decriminalized or legalized.
And what we're seeing already at the state
level bears this out or it's drugs connected
to other crimes as well.
So I think if you were to legalize, decriminalize
and say.
Everybody in prison simply for a personal
possession drug charge is being led out, the
US would still be very, very high in terms
of per capita incarceration globally.
And I don't know that simply decriminalizing
or legalizing personal use amounts is actually
going to be the big improvement from a criminal
justice standpoint, as some people believe
that it's going to be.
Those are the numbers I found.
If you disagree, let me know